if your idea of an autonomous vehicle is
some pod a puttering around your city
you need to think bigger and fiery this
helicopter fights wildfires no human
needed it's called k-max
and it's Lockheed Martin's answer to a
growing problem since the turn of the
millennium wildfires have been wreaking
havoc in the u.s. the fire season is
longer and the damage is more severe in
2015 the u.s. spent more than two
billion dollars battling the flames six
firefighters died in that fight
so the answer Lockheed says is getting
the human out of their autonomous and
unmanned aircraft don't put lives in the
danger zone and they don't have to cater
to human weaknesses like the need to
sleep or eat in a demo in upstate New
York
Lockheed showed off for unmanned
aircraft that joined forces to beat back
fires and save human lives
first up the indigo quadcopter flies
over the area in question using infrared
and visible light cameras to pick out
the hotspots it passes those coordinates
along to the k-max
a cargo helicopter Lockheed retrofitted
to fly itself
k-max heads out stopping first to fill
its bucket from a nearby pond when it
reaches the fire line it dumps to each
to up drenching the ground to contain
the flames holding back a fire is one
thing keeping everybody safe is another
so Lockheed fires up the desert and
surprise this hen launched surveillance
drone spots a lost camper behind the
fire line and so it was up to another
unmanned helicopter this one dubbed
Sarah to make the rescue Sarah does most
of the flying work itself it can even
identify a safe landing zone which is
great for getting to people in tight
spots Lockheed's drones are already
helping fight fires in Australia and
company reps say k-max and Sarah could
join them doing the work for real and in
the u.s. in as little as three years
they can't take off soon enough